not sure exactly we'll see if that comes
up i've got jill tarter here
and jill is patiently waiting for me to
tell her that the stream is working
but i don't see that the stream is
actually working
oh i'm glad somebody else has problems
yeah it's not only uh seti
uh researchers that have trouble oh no
we're live awesome
great let me make sure i have a voice
here awesome it's working
anyway i'm happy you're happy jill
tarter you're a legend you're an
inspiration to me
you endorsed my my uh my piece of
writing here called losing the nobel
prize and i was super super proud to
have your endorsement
it means so much to me where are you
joining us from today jill
oh i'm locked down in berkeley right as
i have been since march
where else would we be if not locked
down here in the lovely state of
california
uh so i thought today it would be
wonderful to have a conversation with
you about
your career but also about all sorts of
interesting questions from our
guests but the first thing i want to ask
is of course
everybody it's burning on everybody's
mind
do you believe in santa claus jill
[Laughter]
this year santa's got a lot to live up
to right
that's right but the real question is do
you believe in
that some sort of intelligence is living
or
might be living near the star system
known as proxima centauri b
and providing us with techno signatures
ah yeah well
first of all the verb believe is the
wrong verb yes because it doesn't matter
what i believe what you believe it's
what is right and so this is a
scientific exploration to try and find
evidence of someone else's technology
and in my case
um the um the proxima b
story is a bit frustrating right it
never should have been made public
uh the observations were done in a way
that is problematic in the sense that
they
did not have um a second simultaneous
observing capability they didn't have
it was actually somebody else's data
looking at something else
and so the the ability
to have any kind of validation
confirmation just wasn't there and you
know i like to say that if i'd been
running the show at ohio state
um you never would have heard about the
wow signal because
the scientists had set up a certain
protocol
certain uh criteria that a signal had to
satisfy in order to be potentially a
candidate
and the wow signal though stronger than
anything they'd heard
did not in fact fulfill those criteria
so
um you got to be willing to say nope
nope
um that's right yes sir so
uh but yes the wow signal kind of does
you know dog the
the field and i've always wondered why
do people
you know put so much credibility in that
in that wow signal it was sort of one
night
one night only and and again yes it's
not about belief we have evidence
it's only saturday yeah so one one seven
second period 72 70 oh 72 seconds yes
and it was never repeated again that
doesn't rule it out but as you say we
look for evidence we are
observationalists i've been having a lot
of conversations on my channel with
nobel laureates and other
esteemed guests and you know at varying
degrees people do
in science have uh some strong amounts
of faith it surprises me
how much faith people have including
things that maybe
in principle can't be proven like like
singularities like
uh like multiple universes and so i've
always wondered you know
when when you do the work that you do
you've always done it quantitatively
and you look for evidence but is there
at any point
you know people say what do you hope to
discover how do you react to that again
it's it's not about belief but surely
you must as a human being although
scientists you know we always say
an outgoing scientist is one who looks
at your shoes when he talks to you or
she talks to you but anyway
as a human being what would it mean to
discover this why is there so much
interest in this particular signal and
in the field of seti in general well
you know the thing that we're interested
in most is ourselves right
that's what people want to talk about
and think about as ourselves
and in this case what we're trying to do
is figure out how we fit into the cosmos
what is our place in the universe uh so
i think that's what intrigues people and
they're you know they're all kinds of
possibilities so
perhaps we will discover another
intelligent
uh technological species out there and
statistically
they're gonna be older than we are right
um
and the question of how you become
an old stable technological civilization
is a very interesting one because we're
in this
adolescent phase right and it's not
clear
that we have a long future but the
detection of a signal
would would show us that it is possible
to have a long future
someone else made it through and and the
reason that
we can guarantee with a single detection
that it's pos that we're talking about a
long future
is the fact that in order to make a
detection
two technological civilizations have to
be close
to one another close spatially and
overlapping in time co-temporal and in a
10 billion year history of this galaxy
the only way that it's likely that two
technological civilizations are going to
be around at the same time
is if they persist for a long time
in cosmic times not in human times and
so
we can have certain confidence
that any signal we detect is going to be
coming from
a long-lived civilization and
just the proof that it's possible to get
there
from where we are today it seems to me
incredibly important and hopeful
yeah when i uh when i heard recently i
had on sarah sieger from mit
uh discussing uh phosphine on venus how
did you react to that
i haven't talked to you about that since
that announcement and the subsequent
uh sort of controversy that's erupted
from it i have had
i do have an invitation i should say to
jane grieves who's the lead author of
the study
she's hopefully going to come on next
early next year but oh how did you react
you know personally did you
were you are the things you'd like to
see i mean i'm happy to put in a word
with
sarah and jane well um
when i when i saw that i thought okay
so here there are two questions did they
get
did they get the right line because it
was a single line identification so
usually when we study molecules in the
interstellar medium and we're looking
for new species
you require multiple uh transitions to
be detected
this is a single transition and secondly
um are we so sure that we have
exhausted all the possibilities in the
chemical network
that could produce phosphine in
conditions that aren't
like our laboratory so
i i think the authors tried to address
both of those but i
think that there's there's room for
skepticism
nevertheless they should have announced
what they found
because you want other people looking at
it you want other people trying to do
additional observations to verify or
negate i had on also the i
just announced it was the i think of the
24th anniversary of the passing of carl
sagan
this year i've had on android and sasha
sagan the first mother-daughter combo
on the into the impossible podcast so
that was quite a treat
um and everyone was sharing the
recollections of of carl sagan so i'd be
remiss if i didn't ask you
about your relax recollections of carl
and working together of course
uh as you guys did and then we'll take
some questions from the audience and uh
i'll talk to you as long and i know
you've got a heartbreak at 12 o'clock
but
what are your recollections of carl
sagan what did he mean to you personally
and to science in general
well carl was a spectacular communicator
he had the ability to get an audience
fired up and enthused and seeing the the
world through his eyes right um
he
he well i had some really
in personal relationships with carl um
so i was undergoing um treatment for
breast cancer while carl was doing his
second round
of um treatment for his
his cancer and so that was a bond i mean
it was
it's it's a strange bond but we we
talked about
how how
mortal we felt and how difficult it was
to tolerate these poisons that you were
ingesting um he
he had had much earlier
carl um who was on our board of trustees
at the seti institute
carl had had some surgery or
exploratory surgery actually to figure
out why he was bleeding out it was a
rupture
of an old scar in his um
his esophagus and after that experience
um carl picked up a little bit of a
king carl attitude that that irked me
right because you know he understood
how little time any of us have and how
important it is to make use of it but
to um to treat secretaries or support
staff
in a way that says i'm more important
than you are right
it it it really irked me but prior to
that carl had been
um a real inspiration and i was back at
cornell
um and went to
a cocktail party at carl's house
and he and annie took me aside and they
said
carl's writing the science fiction novel
and i said oh i know the new york times
just told us what kind of an advance he
got and we're all
so jealous and so
so anne said well you may think that you
recognize someone
in the book but i think you'll like her
and
i said oh come on just just make sure
that she doesn't eat ice cream cones for
lunch
because that was something that i did at
the time
and i got teased a lot about it and
people made all kinds of
um funny remarks about that and
so okay then carl sent me a
pre-publication
copy of contact and i read it and i'm
going
wait wait how does carlo this right
that's me how does he know this and it
turns out that
i'm just absolutely prototypical
of women my age who ended up
entering a male dominated science or
engineering career
and after i got my phd i went to a
meeting in washington dc
sponsored by i think it was the american
institute of
in science um
america well awes whatever that is
and i met i worked i walked into a room
full of 80 women bright
incredibly curious and intelligent
women and i'd never done that i was
always walking into a room full of men
and often i was the only female
so i met these women and it was huge it
changed it was life-changing for me
right
and we sat around and we did this kind
of amateur
psychology how we were trying to figure
out how we made it
through a leaky pipeline when so many
others
had had dripped out and a couple of
things that
surprised me a really
statistically significant majority of
us had been influenced by
our dads when we were young our fathers
were our universe and then our dads had
died
while we were young and it was horrible
but in terms of the impact is
we all learned this important lesson
about carpe diem
right so i if i didn't ask my dad a
question
today i always figured he was going to
be there tomorrow to answer it
and then i learned no you can't count on
that so you really do
have to take advantage of opportunities
when they come along
and so we had all learned that at an
early age
and um it allowed us to to seize
opportunities when they showed up
and the other thing was that we were all
competitive
right but back then it was so early it
was pre-title nine
so we wanted to compete
and there were no women sports that you
could compete
in in high school but the one thing you
could compete for
was being a cheerleader or being a baton
twirler a drum majorette
and so uh on um
you know unexpectedly in a large number
of us
had been trigger leaders or drum
majorettes in our high school careers
so i there was a little study that was
written up after this meeting
and talking to carl one day on the phone
i was i was telling him about this and
and i sent him
that report and that's where he got
i think a lot of the characteristics of
the female protagonist
wow yeah he was certainly uh he was
certainly a titan and had a huge
influence
on me and not only because let's see if
i can find it
we got to get one of you but i've been
using this guy
a lot lately this is of course none
other than my carl sagan sock puppet uh
finger puppet but
and i hope to get one of you made up
commissioned by the unemployed
philosopher's guild so that's the only
plug i'm gonna do actually i'm gonna do
another plug if you'll bear with me for
a second thank everybody for tuning in
to the into the impossible
podcast it's such a treat to have jill
tarter just to have a little break here
jill is of course the subject of the
book making contact here's a picture of
that book
covered by our mutual friend sarah
scholes who wrote that book and she was
a guest this past summer on the into the
impossible podcast
as you know jill uh carpal tunnel
syndrome is one of the
number one reasons that academics don't
write papers so i want everybody to take
a break
and stretch your finger and push the
subscribe button the like button
leave a comment and leave a thumbs up if
you think that aliens are real and that
e.t
is out there somewhere that will help
the show immensely to attract great
talented guests like jill tarter jill as
you know
this is the 60th sorry this is this uh
60th anniversary
of seti in some sense the drake equation
and i believe it was project osmo's is
about that vintage
i want to ask you um i'm getting a
question what is uh
from an uh a person a user by the name
of stock investor i wonder if that's
what his
parents named him but anyway stock
investor asked me to ask you is there
anything
that happened at seti during your uh
tenure there's the bernard or the
bernard oliver chair
um and anything happened there that the
public didn't find out about that you
can talk about
uh there are no conspiracies right
there's no
nothing hidden we did have um
back a long time ago i think it was 97
98
we did have a false positive that kept
us going
for more than a day and
uh indeed it was very it was a really
good case because it showed us that it's
impossible to keep a secret
right we eventually figured out that the
signal that we were getting uh was from
the soho spacecraft in orbit around the
sun
but before um we
got to that conclusion seth rostak and
my colleagues at the seti institute i
was at the observatory
um were getting calls from the media
saying
hmm here's something interesting is
going on you want to talk about it
and fortunately seth said no no not yet
let us work on this for a bit but nobody
had called up
the newspaper to tell them about this
but it did in fact leak out and made us
very
um conscious of the fact that it's going
to be hard
to follow this protocol that we've
established which wants us to
confirm and get an independent
confirmation if possible of a signal
before we tell the world
and actually some people have suggested
of talking with david brin over the
weekend who's uh listening in the chat
room he says hello to you watching you
uh hi david hi everybody out there
uh thank you for tuning in i want to uh
point out that you know david was sort
of suggesting i mean one
pro possibility is that it could be a
hack right the signal proxima century
signal
have you uh do you have protocols
against that in addition to
not you know notifying the media before
passing certain tests but do you have
protocols against hacking
well um we have been hacked in the past
it was pretty obvious and
but nevertheless it caused us to spend
additional telescope time
trying to track down something um that
is actually the reason for this
independent confirmation that we
claim as a gold standard because it's
going to be hard
for someone to do a hack that hacks
two different telescopes when you don't
necessarily know what the second
telescope is going to be for that
independent confirmation
so that's one reason that that's one of
our requirements
we take hacking and i think that we're
an attractive target
yeah yeah this summer i had on david
kaiser
and earlier in the year paul davies who
wrote a book called the eerie silence
and as we come up on the 60th
anniversary and it's the 10th
anniversary
since paul davies booked the eerie
silence
what stock do you put into uh the
evidence
or lack thereof for you know for
potential
not intelligent life but life forms a
shadow biosphere
or maybe even intelligent in the form of
these lurkers that he and the benford
boys
and even david brin have speculated
about
um they're all interesting speculations
there are not yet any data to
corroborate
so um you know
in some sense although 60 years seems
like a long time for humans
it's a very short time um for the cosmos
and if you think about the night
excuse me the nine-dimensional haystack
that we're trying to search through for
this needle that we prize
you know frequencies directions on the
sky modulations polarization
sensitivity all of this stuff um
and i did an exercise when seti turned
50 right and i said okay what's the
range of each of these parameters that
we might need to search in order to find
uh evidence and then i made a
nine-dimensional volume
not sophisticated but just multiplied
all those volumes together and i said
all right
this nine dimension dimensional search
space i'm going to set the volume
of this search base equal to volume of
all the world's oceans
and then ask the question how much of
the oceans have we searched as a
way to make an analogy turned out at age
50 we'd searched
one glass of the ocean by
10 years later it was more like a small
hot tub so we're getting better
we're getting bigger um and
exponentially fast yeah
but you know if you're looking at to
answer the question are
are there any fish in the ocean and you
dip a glass of water a glass
into the ocean and look at what comes
out and you don't see any fish
you're not going to conclude i don't
think that there are no fish in the
ocean but you're going to conclude that
you need a bigger glass
or more of them right you haven't
searched very
hard and so i don't think
we should be surprised that after 60
years we haven't
found any evidence even if life and
technology out there is abundant
this there's a great the last sentence
of the initial 1959 coconia morrison
paper
says something that's very wise it says
probability of success
is difficult to estimate but if you
never search
chance of success is zero yeah and
that's the way i look at it yeah the the
great uh seti researcher wayne gretzky
said
you miss every shot you don't take i
think that's
that's the same kind of uh sentiment
that you're expressing
yes i remember uh back in 2001 actually
in 2000 i was a postdoc at stanford
and i i've conveyed this to you that i
wouldn't be sitting here at least at uc
san diego and this branch of the
of the uh wave function in the many
worlds interpretation
were it not for you as i described uh in
my book that you came to
uh to stanford to give a wonderful
colloquium i begged my
uh friends and the faculty there to let
me come to dinner with jill she's my
hero
and uh and and i eventually connived my
way into it
but uh through a torture series of
events i ended up getting fired after
that but but that's not a big deal we'll
we can postpone that uh that branch of
the wave function for some other time
uh i'm getting uh questions that people
are are curious about
uh these this you know kind of notion of
searching and the nine dimensional
playing field like you talked about
maybe you can explain what that is and
how
looking in other wave bands that were
really just on the horizon
uh back in 2000 when i first met you uh
that are now becoming more popular
including my
close colleague and friend shelly wright
who's a professor at uc san diego here
with me
are looking in different wavelengths
does that add to this multi-dimensional
haystack
and first of all what does that haystack
mean okay so
um let me enumerate on my finger so i
may make sure i get nine
unless you're an alien you'll get eight
so there are um are three dimensions in
space
that we need to explore there's
a time dimension right there's
the whole question of frequency or
wavelength
what where should we be looking in the
electromagnetic spectrum
assuming that the right thing to be
looking for is a signal
there's modulation is there information
on that signal
how is it encoded and how will that
detect
how will that affect the kinds of
detectors that we need to build
and lastly how sensitive do we have to
be
because we don't know how powerful a
transmitter might be
or how far away it is and so
those are the the nine dimensions that
we need to um
look through even if um we've made the
right
assumption that it's an electromagnetic
signal we should be looking for
there have been some interesting
speculations in science fiction about
information being encoded on
gravitational waves
on other forms of communication
possibilities other particles
that go between stars we
have reasons for favoring the
electromagnetic spectrum but those
reasons
are not necessarily absolute they have
to do with the physics that we currently
understand they have to do with the
technology
that we have in the 21st century so you
know we
freely admit that we might be doing um
an absolutely fantastic
job at exactly the wrong search
but until we develop a new technology or
some new physics points us in a
different direction
we don't know what else to search for
and if you
put on your bayesian cap
i'm getting a question from a listener
kumasan who's asking
what is it uh more likely in your
opinion
or based on bayesian reasoning would
aliens be
similar to us in some sense i've always
made the point i'll make it to you
i made it to paul davies and he slapped
me around but i said you know we
wouldn't be having you know these
conversations or even this technology if
it wasn't for
you know dinosaurs existing on earth and
you made a joke in your in your ted talk
which i'll put a link to
you know the dinosaurs didn't have a
really good space program if they did
they might still be here
which i agree with and and the question
of you know whether or not
uh one can uh one can exist though as a
technological civilization we exist
because of it
because the dinosaurs no longer exist
perhaps and and we certainly
owe a lot of our longevity to planets
like jupiter and saturn
that just participated in this grand
conjunction
from our vantage point uh and so without
those planets those gas
we might have been bombarded early on
during the heavy early bombardment
so what you know in your mind is more
likely uh
that that there would be another type of
intelligent
technological life form as you've often
emphasized to me
and elsewhere or that there's you know
microbial slime
which which would be interesting or
phosphine generating
you know microbes uh which would be
interesting but not technological with
that kind of
uh dichotomy would you expect that
aliens are more likely to be like us or
more likely to be like
uh bacteria well from our point of view
in terms of trying to look for techno
signatures doesn't matter
right they have to have the ability to
build some sort of
transmitter or to modify their
environment in ways that are
visible from long distances whether
they're a colonial
entity made up of lots of small
microscopic
uh part of entities or whether they're
you know big like us with opposable
thumbs and the ability to build things
it really doesn't matter because we're
not looking
for them precisely we're looking for the
results of
their actions how they use technology
right and there's a book by adam uh
frank i think at rochester
called light of the stars in which he
says that the most you know
most promising signature techno
signature maybe
would be looking for global warming or
some greenhouse effect that would show
you know agriculture is
is happening perhaps
that's hard to do it is yes we need to
get we're beginning to get the
technologies to
image exoplanets and derive some
information from
from those images but you know the
brightness contrast and the optical
between a planet and its is 10 to the
10th
in the infrared it's only 10 to the 8th
but it is really difficult
to make an image of a dim small
object so close to a very bright
star they we're getting there and it's
really exciting i mean that's the only
reason
i'm bummed about being old is because
it's going to take a while to get those
kinds of observing
capabilities and i might not be around
to see what we find
and i i'm curious yes i'll ask you about
that later on as i come to the uh
to the end and 15 20 minutes but um i
want to go back to some of your other
you've had this uh storied career and in
history of
astronomy as one of our pioneering
astronomers
and in many ways and and really being
the driving force behind
set i can praise you in ways that might
make you uncomfortable but
uh but i'd say to seth shostak and i
have said it to him but i want to ask
you
turning back to your original work on on
objects that thanks to you are called
brown dwarfs do you keep up with that
research the research that you did
back in the you know in the late 70s for
example or
have you just sort of left that to other
other folks well i read about it
but it's not something that i've spent
any time
trying to push forward uh yeah it was
it was fun and the
as a thesis topic my
advisor um was wondering about what at
the time
we called missing mass right the
looking at the velocities of stars
at the edges of our galaxy
we concluded that there needed to be
more gravitational mass
somehow then we could add up by
the masses of all the stars and dust and
gas
and so what could these be and and the
question was well
you know it's a different set of physics
that determines
whether a collapsing get a cloud of gas
um gets hot enough at its core to
burn uh hydrogen to helium
and shine that's a different set of
physics and the then the physics that
determines
um how many stars of what
mass you create when
a molecular cloud collapses and
so we were thinking that maybe
um there are enough tiny tiny stars
that don't have enough mass to burn
stably hydrogen to helium and those
might be sitting out there and
they might be responsible for this
missing mass
and if so what would they look like how
would you find them observationally
so that's what i was working on on my
thesis and you know you you create
actually plus using bomb codes from
livermore
to make the uh interior model of the
star
and then you need to put an atmosphere
on the outside to
to see how the radiation actually gets
out
at what rate but i couldn't given the
atmospheres
i'm sorry the opacity tables of the time
low temperature low
pressure they're terrible and i could
never make it work
so i could never tell you what color
these little things might be
and edmund land once said brown is not a
color
so supposed to black dwarfs or red
dwarfs or
um infrared dwarfs and just call them
brown dwarfs
and the names stuck i was speaking
there's a lot more missing mass than we
once thought right that's the whole dark
matter
right yeah i was speaking last night
with giant narlikar
who is a giant of cosmology and worked
with fred hoyle
back in the 60s for his phd thesis at
cambridge and of course they were the
most prominent ardent defenders of the
steady state model and actually giant
still believes that at age 88 or so and
that interview will come out on the
dr brian keating youtube channel and on
into the impossible podcast again please
everybody exercise your finger
buy the book making contact by sarah
scholes
jill gets uh 35 percent of every book so
i'm just kidding
she doesn't get that but i do want to
make an announcement the institute does
get something so yes
and i'm actually going to make an
announcement i am going to match any
super chat
any donation through youtube at least
any super chat
i will match two to one in my annual
donation to the seti institute
so please do that if you want to give
some money i will double it
because i love the mission that they
that they are doing they're
really the the best i know you spoke
disparagingly about cheerleaders but i
act as a cheerleader for seti institute
because
seti does such great work not just for
looking for extraterrestrial
intelligence and so forth which is the
most one of the most interesting things
if not the most interesting thing
besides cosmology
that one could study but because they do
so much awesome
actual astronomy and scientific outreach
so please give
i will double it at a minimum up to
unlimited amounts although i don't know
how much a norwegian kroner is
stock investor it's his second a hundred
dollar 100
norwegian kroner donation he asks or
she asks what does jill consider the
biggest achievements
of the seti program
i think uh now in my old philosophical
age
that our biggest achievement to date
has to make it has been to make people
uh change their perspective right so
talking with you giving lectures talking
to people around the world
and getting them to think seriously
about the idea of life beyond earth
life that would be spectacularly
different
from us because it evolved and
co-evolved in a different planet
or in a different way i think that whole
exercise is like holding up a mirror
to all of the humans on this planet
and saying look all of you in that
mirror
you're all the same when compared to
something else
out there and it trivializes
the differences among humans that we
sometimes fight wars and kill one
another over
and i think it's really important to
instill this cosmic perspective
because we have all these challenges
that we're going to have to solve
and they don't respect national
boundaries right we're gonna have to
figure out
how to work globally and cooperatively
and i think that if seti can help
people out there have this perspective
of being an earthly
and and behaving that way i think we can
go
a long way to making sure that we do
have a long future
that's very good so um now there's a
question
about uh what's the other thing we did
to be concrete
right we built the allen telescope yes
so
we for the first time we built a large
um an array out of a large number of
small dishes
and proved that that can work that we
now have enough
computing capability to uh
combine the signals from all those
telescopes in interesting ways
and now as we go into the future the
square kilometer array
um the next generation vla they're all
going to be built
as this large number of small dish
concept and
so i'm very proud that we demonstrated
that at the seti institute and at uc
berkeley that this can work
yeah oh great we're getting a lot of
good uh donations here thank you so much
reminder i will donate a match two to
one for the seti institute any amounts
donated in the super chat
or you can uh you can also venmo me at
dr bryant dr brian keating if you like i
will double
any contributions made today uh jill i
want to ask you
we hear often as sarah wrote in her
follow-up to the smash hit
making contact she wrote a book called
they are already here
about why human beings are seeing
saucers so i want to ask about that
um why do we see saucers does that
interest you and
have there been any credible sightings
to your opinion
these navy fighter pilots we hear about
all the time
is any of that convincing to you not yet
and i think it's just the 21st century's
version of angels and archangels
how so what does that mean well um it's
what we
see it's what we think about it's what
we project
onto uh sightings
of things that we don't understand i
mean 20 years ago
there was people were saying
that there were all of these ufos
associated with large
thunder clouds and when we got enough
um and including pilots
flying at high altitudes and then when
we got enough
satellites that were looking down at the
earth with enough time resolution
we found out that lightning travels up
as well as down
right so these are now called sprites
and elves and it was a new piece of
physics that we
discovered and i think that
people see things they really do see
things
i think the problem is the
interpretation
of those things having to do with
spacecraft that's where
we are lacking in evidence
and yes i always see things there was a
podcast by
uh david fraver who's a navy fighter
pilot on lex friedman who's got a very
popular podcast
alex is interested in all sorts of
things extraterrestrial
but uh he made this big point about how
pilots are you know really good at
seeing things that are far away and
spatial relations and so
i'm a pilot uh you know private pilot as
i know you are
as well although i don't know if you're
still current um i would take you up in
a heartbeat someday we'll have to do
that
uh but uh but you know i once got pulled
over by a police officer for speeding
and it was right after i passed my test
i thought i was a young
chuck chuck yeager uh remember rest in
peace
and i said well listen officer you know
i'm
skilled at hand-eye coordination and i
know all these things he's like that's a
totally different skill set
and he said i'm a pilot and if i have to
rely on my hand-eye coordination i'm
gonna crash
so i i discount these things as well uh
and yet i think there's a lot of
resistance there's this uh gentleman
mick west are you familiar with him jill
no actually that's someone that i've not
encountered he does the debunking uh
michael shermer has has
helped to popularize some of this as
well as a friend and former guest but
mick west is doing work to kind of show
how you could get the exact same pattern
these so-called tic tac patterns etc
so i think it's worth listening to lex
friedman's podcast number 122. he
mentions this
at some point let's see we only have
about 15 minutes left i want to make
sure i get all my guests reminder we're
talking with
my friend and role model and the reason
i'm here in san diego
dr uh jill tarter uh who is joining us
and uh i wanna i um sort of understand
where is it
um where is the seti institute's allen
telescope array
where is that uh what what is its
current status i know that
uh the making contact describes it as
sort of a cliffhanger
where it's at currently but uh how big
into the ocean how many uh uh
hot tubs per per year can we expect to
be searching with allen telescope
well the island scope is in northern
california
um close to mount lassen
and so if you if you are going to visit
flashing national park you should come
on down the road
and stop by and see the allen telescope
array we currently have 42
six meter dishes our initial ambition
was to build 350
but you know we thought we'd done all
the technology development until we
started to build and
we found out there's a lot more to do
and so
we we ran out of money before we could
get to 350 and if you're gonna stop
somewhere
uh seemed to me 42 was the right place
right it's a lucky number you know why
do you know why it's a lucky number not
in addition to uh the hitchhiker's gun
it's it's the most fortuitous number
there is
oh that's a girl you didn't sorry oh
that's sorry yes
i'm a dad what can i say we're uh
we we first began observing in 2007 and
right now we're retrofitting um
the antennas with a new spectacular feed
designed in in most part by my husband
and that feed allows us to look at
more bandwidth at any moment and
to have a lower system temperature so to
be able to see
fainter sources and we're in the we're
in the process of doing that and again
it's one of these things where
um we have some
funding uh from franklin antonio he's
here in san diego
but it it you know we don't have all the
funding we
we would like to have and so it's going
a bit slower
it's being used uh on and off
to do steady observations and also to
observe fast radio bursts
right these mysterious radio sources uh
that are coming
from most of them from extra galactic
distances
and trying to understand what the
physics is there so
uh we're not on the the air with our
standard 24 hour a day seven day a week
steady observing program
um but we're getting there and looking
forward to being back
to doing those observing observations
and it's
it's one of these things you do it from
your bedroom right this remotely
controlled telescope that
works on its own and and hopefully
doesn't miss any signals and and
announces to us when there are
interesting things that it needs help
figuring out
is um is it possible that uh well so
what's the status of seti at home is
that
is that no longer active right now it is
no longer active they shut it down
earlier this year
um there are lots and lots of data
and they need to spend some time
understanding what it is that they have
detected thus far
very good yes yeah it was one of the
first citizen science
campaigns extremely popular and i think
it was almost a victim of its own
success in some ways because it was
so powerful it could uh it could occupy
a lot of uh
otherwise dead cycles that other
otherwise uh
well-intentioned corporations like
google and dropbox would like to be
using
so uh but hopefully it will be uh it'll
always be
well hopefully it'll be resuscitated at
some point and uh
and i wanna uh congratulate uh seti pro
uh um seti had home for so i think it
was 20 years at least
that it uh yes yeah so uh we're coming
to the end of the
we always get um asked about seti at
home but that
actually was a very clever project out
of uc berkeley right yeah that was part
of berkeley
um and uh so yeah so i want to uh
ask a couple more questions from the
audience uh
first of all william uh willie i can't
pronounce it i think it's willie
well i am uh is asking what is is there
a protocol
if we do detect if you're if we are
successful and kind of uh having a
a uh unambiguous message from an
extraterrestrial technological
civilization is there a protocol to deal
with that
well yes there has been a protocol for a
very long time starting back in the 80s
under the auspices of the international
academy of astronautics and the
international institute of space law
we tried to figure out what we should do
and indeed we we started this protocol
um so-called post-detection protocol
as a way to encourage our soviet uh
colleagues to have some backing that
they should
having decided that what they were
seeing was real
and potentially an e.t signal um to give
them the backing that
would allow them to tell the world right
because
it wasn't clear that that information
would ever get out of the former soviet
union
and over the years that protocol has has
morphed
when we were a nasa project there was a
step in there
that described which associate
administrator
would uh notify the executive branch
right so now that we're no longer an
asset project and privately funded that
that's left
but it's still basically common sense
so you do everything that you can at the
discovery site
with what tools you have available there
to show that
there's really something that you think
you're seeing and then
because of hacking and just to have
verification you go and get an
independent confirmation
from a telescope that has software you
didn't write
and hardware you didn't build and if
they if they can confirm it then
the next step is to tell the world and
what you tell the world depends on the
nature of what you're seeing
because you'd like to have as many
different facilities
with as many different types of
detectors
looking at this and trying to figure out
what it is
so we do tell the world but not
instantly
because we want to get this independent
confirmation
and then uh kumasan is asking what is
the impact of the loss of our beloved
arecibo radio telescope
well arecibo was certainly prior to fast
uh in china arecibo was our most
sensitive
telescope and we um
up until 2004 we were fortunate enough
to have
something like 15 or 20 percent of time
on that telescope to
to do steady observations in 2004 we
decided we wanted to be on the air 24 7
and began building
our own telescope on the allen telescope
array
but arecibo uh has
some unique characteristics it has
a planetary radar it has a
2 2 megawatt transmitter
that with the large dish has a huge gain
and can focus this transmitter
onto an asteroid for example it can
um uh
improve the determination of the
asteroids
orbit after it's been detected but it
also can actually
map the shape of the asteroid
and so that planetary radar the unique
there's there is a radar at goldstone on
a much smaller telescope
but that's a loss sensitive radio
astronomy observations of millisecond
pulsars as part of a pulsar timing
program
in the nanograph project which
involves a lot of observatories around
the globe but arecibo
when you put that into the mix really
did
improve the sensitivity so yeah
it's it's sad um but it just shows you
how difficult it is
to maintain high technology
in a very trying environment
of community insult so uh thank you i
have a question a super chat from my
good friend jacob kuhn who's been
helping out with this live stream jacob
thank you so much 10 bucks
which will get turned into 20 bucks last
chance for folks to donate and have
the money taken out of this poor state
university professor salary but i love
to do it because seti institute
deserves every penny and i am a long
time donor
uh frequent speaker and just uh one of
the biggest fans of the seti institute
and all that i have to be honest is
thanks to jill don't say anything jill
uh to seth because he'll get jealous and
he won't give me that cup of coffee i'm
really waiting for that cup of coffee
in 2027 i think he's gonna give it to me
but jacob is asking
are we going to put a telescope on the
moon and will it have any
uh validity or any uh utility for seti
searches
oh well we're talking about it in
particular on the lunar far side
because when you think about all of the
orbital
assets that we're putting around this
planet with
lots and lots of transmitters it's
getting pretty radio
loud and we spend more than half of our
computing trying to discriminate
what we call radio frequency
interference from something that
actually may be coming
from a distant star so the lunar far
side is quiet
we recognize this long ago i think it
was 1974
um the astronomical unit union went to
the itu
and said um let's create something
called the shielded zone
the shielded zone of the moon in which
there will be no transmitters
so we've been thinking about it um
unfortunately nasa's planning to build a
gateway
um right above in orbit above that
shielded zone of the moon
so we're hoping that we can convince
them that as they build this
with communications capability they
build it so that
there are two frequencies so it's
at one time we'll get to be able to
listen at all frequencies on
uninterfered with
so um the the challenge is
likely to be regolith and how
how it impacts anything with moving
parts you know the the apollo astronauts
came back
into the air capsule coated in this dust
and it even
got into their lungs so it's very um
it's hard to work with
but particularly with low frequency
uh receivers which could in fact have no
moving parts
um but just be essentially
huge dipoles wrapped up in a in a
polyurethane
um case and pulled out on the lunar
surface to
expose them um that low frequency is is
possible from the moon at lower
frequencies than we can observe from
earth because of the
ionospheric cut off that we have here so
the lunar far side has a lot going for
it
um i think it's probably
above my capabilities to try and raise
the funds for that so
we're going to do that if we do it we're
going to do it in conjunction
with something else that is going to the
far side of the moon to create
infrastructure
well who knows you might get a call from
a billionaire orbiting around and
some satellite in the not too distant
future i hope you do
and i think it's just so amazing the
work that you've done and you're
inspiring literally millions of people
around the world jill in addition to the
way you've inspired me and been a role
model to me
uh now i want to finish up with the uh
final three questions that i ask all my
guests if you're game
before we uh release each other to our
respective telecons
uh the first one is i want to ask you uh
if you were to leave an ethical will not
a material will
but an ethical will which is uh sort of
similar to what alfred nobel did as i
described in losing the nobel prize he
not only endowed
you know these golden pieces of
medallion that i've been stealing off of
all my guests who come on who have nobel
prizes and didn't lose them they
actually won them
but alfred said the invention or
discovery must be
for the benefit of humankind uh so it
was an ethical will plus a material will
i want to ask you
what sort of wisdom would you like to
leave for your biological
progeny but also your ideological
progeny which i i count myself as one
i would really like to turn earthling
into a meme
right i would like everyone
uh to go to their electronic devices and
pull up the profiles that describe them
and have them
write the first thing about themselves
is that they're in earthlings and then
i'd like to have them
behave that way to to
actually internalize this cosmic
perspective
and behave as global citizens
very good now the next question harkens
to
the name of this podcast i will get to
is into the impossible and that
relates to sir arthur c clarke's famous
three laws we'll get there in one second
but before we do this i want to ask you
about uh arthur c clarke you've surely
seen
2001 a space odyssey in the movie
many times okay it's still in
pigment yes yes my uh my my chagrin
always comes when i talk to somebody
who's a sci-fi fan
they say no i've never seen the movie
but anyway i'm glad that you've seen it
you'll recall
there are very many uh sort of very
interesting
kind of forecasts for the future but one
of them kind of goes into the into the
future
really far when the primates on the
savannah of africa
and later on the surface of the moon are
in space uh the characters encounter
this monolith
this menacing black obelisk thing that
seems to be like a time capsule meant to
last for
a billion years and i always ask my
guests what would you put on a time
capsule that you knew
would last for a billion years and i
actually asked your friend andrew
in this and she said i did it i i put my
brain waves on
on the voyager golden disk and sent it
out for four billion years nasa told her
but i want to ask you jill what would
you put on a monolith what uh what sort
of fact about
the of of the universe would you think
most deserves
projection into the future
i would say that we were
we were here we were many then perhaps
not so many
but all of us were curious and that's
what
humanity is about being curious and
trying to understand our place in the
cosmos
very nice and the final question before
we both break for our telecons i always
thought that astronomers would be on
telescopes but were mostly on telecons
is that not right
indeed so the last one allows us to zoom
no pun intended uh backwards in time so
arthur c clarke had these three laws the
first one which we open
our podcast up with is this actual voice
saying the following
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic his second law is that for every
expert
there's an equal and opposite expert and
his third law is
the only way of discovering the limits
of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and that's the origin of the name of
this podcast i want to ask you
uh sort of advice to your former self
what aspect of life
what mysterious feature of your future
would you like to demystify and give
advice to your former self to have the
courage
to go into the impossible
yeah um i would say
to be bolder than i was
in terms of ignoring
the conflation of ufos and little green
men
with seti and to um
to have the conviction that this
scientific exploration
is really worth doing it may be
multi-generational
so we have to get clever about how we
funded
generation upon generation and um
just don't listen to them right do your
thing
and do it scientifically do it
rigorously don't ever
regret anything that you've um
that you've done or um that you've
written
and just go for it and and think out of
the box
right so electromagnetic radiation yeah
how and encoding well there's something
that we're beginning to know about now
that we didn't know when i was in
graduate school called
quantized photon angular momentum
which might be a way of encoding
information
and so um yeah just
just keep going put your head down and
ignore the noise
and just keep doing what you think is
worthwhile well
i want to thank you so much for going
into the impossible i want to
ask my uh all my listeners and and
friends out there in cyberspace to thank
you for your
support please do subscribe to the
podcast subscribe to
wherever you get them subscribe to my
email list which you can get on dr
brianketing.brianketing.com and you'll
get a huge ebook that i put together
from my conversations with leading
astronomers
replicating the great debate because
that's 100 years old this year
in addition to the hubble space
telescope and the international space
station are 20 and 30 years reverse
colonel anyway i screwed it up but
jill we love you uh we're so uh honored
that you came on the show
thank you for being a friend uh to me
personally an inspiration to millions
around the world
and i wish you the best of health and
luck in 2021
thank you brian it's been fun i've never
been thanked for getting somebody fired
before
that is provocative and cryptic but read
the read the book you'll find out more
and
jill have a wonderful rest of your of
your year and next year
as well take care everybody bye bye bye
joe
everybody thank you for joining on the
into the impossible podcast as i said
please
exercise your fingers regularly click
subscribe hit the notification bell and
leave a comment
on what jill and seti means to you and
what you'd like to see them do
i will take a few more uh donations it
looks like we got
over 150 dollars so hopefully they'll be
getting a nice bonus and maybe they can
use that to upgrade their
radio receiver technology uh but for now
i want to uh uh just let you know we've
got some great guests coming up as i
mentioned giant narlikar a giant of
cosmology one of the leading
figures of alternative cosmology the
steady state
what do we have to learn from that
you'll find out very soon
lord martin reese is on the show he
reads my horoscope
and tells me what's coming up in 2021
the mysteries of the heavens and lastly
not leastly we have ray weiss who is the
godfather
of of astronomical telescopes using
gravity and microwaves
as he's played a huge role did a
wonderful interview with him i know
you're going to enjoy it
and we're hopefully getting a really
cool uh guest as well in the new year
john preskill going to have deepak
chopra now before you get mad at me
it's not only deepak chopra we're going
to have uh frank wilchuk hopefully with
deepak chopra
leonard milad now as well we're going to
have a hopefully a live stream that we
can all
kind of ask questions and do so as we
love to do
with humility with honor and with
dignity and respect of all these guests
because
everybody has something to learn and as
mahatma gandhi said
the only way to uh to go into the
impossible no the only way to succeed
and is to subdue your ego and act more
humbly than the dust
and as you know dust is the villain of
losing the nobel prize
uh anyway guys this has been fun i'm
getting loopy it's the end of the year
it's been an awesome year there's still
more live streams to come
as i said so stay tuned this week i'm
not signing off for the year yet
i'll let you know when that happens
it'll be midnight on uh
december 31st take care everybody i
gotta go to my telecon
i dropped my mouse but we'll get out of
here somehow or another
take care everybody bye bye
you